Ask any movie industry fan or studio executive,
and they’ll tell you the same thing: R-Rated
movies almost always make less money than
a PG blockbuster at the box office – and
if the movie you’re making CAN appeal to
fans of all ages, then it definitely SHOULD.
At least, that’s what they used to say…
but Deadpool may have changed all that.
The Merc with a Mouth’s road to reality
wasn’t easy, with the final rating one of
the most debated topics among fans.
Would it play it safe at PG-13, and water
down the crudeness of the hero, or go for
the R, doing justice to the insane violence
and humor of the source material – but earning
less money?
Fox went with the latter, and boy did it pay
off.
Not only has Deadpool soared to become an
even faster money-maker than any Marvel solo
movie, but one of the most profitable R-Rated
movies of all time.
And it hasn’t taken long for rumors of an
R-Rated revolution to start.
From an R-Rated Wolverine movie to even an
R-Rated cut of Zack Snyder’s Batman V Superman,
fans are already worried that the success
of Deadpool is going to have some nasty side
effects.
We’re breaking down the real reason Deadpool
succeeded, and why other studios should, and
shouldn’t take a lesson from the foul-mouthed
blockbuster in our latest docu video, How
R-Rated Superhero Movies Could Change The
Game.
R-Rated Failures
First, a reality check: part of the reason
that Deadpool was such a surprise hit, is
because so many hardcore comic movies before
it were disappointments, or failures.
The rise of comic book blockbusters in the
21st century may have implied that any comic
adaptation would be a hit, but studios soon
learned that stamping the words “based on
the graphic novel” on their movie wasn’t
enough.
And as much as some might suggest today, over-the-top
violence and adult humor didn’t help, either.
Even movies with passionate fan bases, like
Marvel’s Punisher, or the ultra-violent
Dredd seemed to prove that cutting kids out
of the comic book equation sliced their profits
in half.
And where The Punisher became a cult success,
but struggled among critics, even the critically
praised and stylish Dredd couldn’t break
out of its R-Rated shell.
Deadpool is lonely among high-grossing R-Rated
features, so if studios think the facts have
changed, we’d bet they’re in for a rude
awakening, since Deadpool might be the exception
that proves the rule.
What Actually Earns an R-Rating?
You’d think it would be common knowledge,
but the content that actually earns a movie
the R-Rating isn’t always clear.
So fans might assume that Deadpool’s blood,
gore, violence, sex scenes, and mile-a-minute
adult humor is a good indicator.
But even small moments and split-second shots
can make all the difference.
For instance, Joss Whedon’s Avengers got
an initial R-Rating for the method and bloodiness
of Agent Phil Coulson’s death.
A few cuts were made around it, and a wide
PG-13 release was in the bag.
In other words: the difference between PG
and R CAN be a sizable one, but fans shouldn’t
assume the worst.
In fact, the first trailer for DC’s Suicide
Squad seemed to guarantee an R-Rating.
The fact that it was announced to be gentle
enough for PG-13 confirms that a movie’s
rating isn’t the whole story.
What Does It Mean For The Movies?
In the short term, it’s hard to know just
how much interest there is in capitalizing
on the surprise success of Deadpool’s R-Rated
action and comedy.
But fans probably don’t need to worry that
the integrity or plot of anticipated movies
will feel a difference – at this point,
a comic book adventure written and directed
for a mass audience isn’t guaranteed to
make MORE money by adding in any R-Rated content.
That doesn’t mean studios aren’t eager
to capitalize on the R-Rated buzz, or the
assumption that an R-Rating might be just
as promising or “true to the character”
for its own story.
In the wake of Deadpool, it was the third
Wolverine movie that gained attention, with
rumors that it could pursue the same rating.
But that’s not the whole story.
After all, the X-Man’s second solo movie
was filmed with an R-Rating in mind, too.
The sequences, swearing and blood were all
filmed knowing that they might be cut for
a PG-13 rating – which they were – but
were added in for the Extended Cut home release.
In other words, knowing that the next Wolverine
movie is aiming for R doesn’t say much,
since the last one did the same.
But Deadpool’s success could convince Fox
that releasing the uncut, original version
of the movie wouldn’t cost them much.
And the ticket sales they DID lose could be
offset by the added marketing, advertising
“Wolverine’s first R-Rated adventure,”
and the most faithful version fans have seen.
But what stirred up even more controversy
was the idea that the Big Blue Boy Scout himself,
Superman, could be swallowed up by the R-Rated
fad, with Batman V Superman’s own home video
release earning an R. Again, things weren’t
as critics immediately assumed.
Most elements of Superman’s origin in Man
of Steel went over kids’ heads, so in his
showdown with Batman, younger fans might see
two superheroes duking it out, but older viewers
would grasp the battle of politics, ideologies,
morality, and acceptable levels of violence
actually taking place.
The marketing has promised the same themes
and ideas as any R-Rated film, not to mention
a brutal fistfight between the heroes, and
Bruce Wayne’s promise to make Superman bleed.
Knowing that a bit of blood and gore earned
Marvel’s family-friendly Avengers an R-Rating,
it’s not crazy to think that Zack Snyder
crossed the same line.
Possibly, more than once.
Theaters won’t see those scenes, but an
‘Unrated Cut’ like Wolverine’s seems
like a no-brainer (for older fans who are
actually intrigued).
Classifying the R-Rated cut in the wake of
Deadpool may be a clever marketing move on
DC’s part, and a win-win: allow a bigger
audience at the theater, and cash in on R-Rated
superhero fans months later.
But if Zack Snyder already had to cut the
scenes in question, like he did before releasing
the Unrated Cut of Watchmen, then an “R-Rated
Batman V Superman” was completed months
before Deadpool hit theaters.
But that may be a sign that some old mistakes
are being repeated.
More on that in a minute…
Repeating Past Mistakes
Sure, R-Rated heroes like Spawn, Deadpool
and The Punisher prove that some stories need
to be told to adults to be told right at all,
but the ugly truth is that those dark, brooding,
violent heroes came from a decade filled with
imitators.
Alan Moore’s “Watchmen” and Frank Miller’s
“Dark Knight Returns” elevated the comic
book artform by going dark; and publishers
chased the success of dark, amoral, violent
stories overnight.
The result was a mess of excessively grim,
adult, dark characters that almost killed
DC and Marvel.
So even though there’s a chance, and a place
for dark, serious superhero movies to make
it big, movie studios chasing the same prize
that the publishers did could result in a
similar crisis.
An R-Rated Batman V Superman cut may not be
copying anything but Zack Snyder and Warner
Bros.’ vision.
Which is a completely different conversation
to be had.
What Does The Future Hold?
The good news is that instead of looking at
their superhero movies and asking how they
can earn an R-Rating, studio executives may
give scripts and characters a second look,
when their adult content may have seemed like
a problem.
But if Deadpool can work by being a good story,
with ratings an afterthought, then why can’t
Batman?
Or Lobo?
Or Moon Knight?
Or Carnage and Venom (Marvel characters)?
Hit movies won’t be any easier to make,
and studios will have to resist the mistakes
of the past.
But after Deadpool, no comic book movie will
ever be written off because it will only appeal,
or be shown to adults.
And that is good news for everyone involved.
Those are our thoughts on the shocking success
of Deadpool’s big screen debut, and how
the movie industry could, and should, react.
But what do you think?
Let us know in the comments, and remember
to subscribe to our channel for more videos
like this one.